Jelly Roll Just testified before
Congress about the drug crisis
overtaking the country he's a former
drug dealer himself and the way that we
talk about that crisis and the way that
we talk about crime broadly I also
understand the Paradox of my history as
a drug dealer standing in front of this
committee but equally I think that's
what makes me perfect to talk about this
I was a part of the problem I am here
now standing as a man that wants to be a
part of the solution I believed when I
sold drugs genuinely that selling drugs
was a victimless crime I truly believe
that
y'all my father always told me what
doesn't get you in the wash will get you
in the rents now I have a 15-year-old
daughter whose mother is a drug addict
every day I get to look in the eyes of a
victim in my household of the effects of
drugs every single day what doesn't get
you in the wash will get you in the
rinse I really like that line I'm going
to have to use that line I think that's
a great insight